good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy tuesday that
feels like a monday but it's not a
monday cause it's a four-day work week
thanks to memorial day and then you
remember it's a tuesday and then it's a
four-day work week even though you think
it's a monday and you have a smile on
your face
that was me today giving such monday and
then i remember it's tuesday i'm like
girl we can do this we can definitely do
this like i have faith in us we're gonna
rise we're gonna grind we're gonna shine
shine like we always do and like do we
look different to you guys like
at all we should we should
because we're especially me we're
literally tick tock famous like i don't
know if you guys were keeping up over
the weekend but your girls went hella
viral over a million views in one of our
podcast clips so um if you're new here
welcome if tick tock brought you here
thank you i hope we don't let you down
no we won't we won't we won't all
weekend claudio was sending me the
updates of like how viral we were going
the funny comments and then she was
screenshotting comments so i could read
them and just like the talkers love us
no they were loving jackie of course
like it's my page the clip that's like
i'm not even in um that's the one that
goes viral it's fine like tick-tock is
paphomic it's totally fine um whatever i
got the views so like that's literally
all that matters you got the views you
got the views you got the views
yeah you got the views everybody
[Laughter]
get on the top
get me back on the talk one we're
posting such premium content too there
have been other morning toast pages that
are posting clips from toast past well
what happened was like like maybe two
weeks ago
out of nowhere like all these morning
toasts fan tic toc pages started two
there's three now [ __ ] okay
don't speak on things you don't know do
not speak on things you don't know okay
you just made it seem like oh like oh
yeah like a thousand um and they started
posting all these clips and it's just
like was reminding me how funny we are
and these clips were going so viral i'm
like let me get in on that like you know
i'm so desperate for tick-tock fame
right um so out of my jealousy we hired
a new video editor and we've been making
premium content for reals and you know
that's just like the kids like if you
want to grow these days like you got to
be posting reals you got to be posting
tick tocks so we're like with the with
the kids you know i love it and also i
love it because the other pages are
posting
our history you know the archive clips
which we love to relive all the time and
we're posting clips from the daily show
so there's space for all of us no but
like the toast is taking over tick tock
i just like i want people it's about
damn time a hundred percent every time
we do something funny people are like
you should make that a tick tock we're
just so lazy how do you do that yeah but
now we're doing it now we're doing it
we're doing so feel free to like do it
yeah maybe we need to do some shorter
clips so that people can like memorize
yeah let's do a clip right now
i can tell you about another children's
book
well yeah that's the one that went viral
for those who maybe don't know it was
jackie talking about the cat in the hat
and the campers and it was just really
like
iconic really iconic because everybody
loves the cat in the hat it's so true i
don't think there's one person out there
who's like what's that
a hat
crazy funky junkie cat haren slept her
entirely channel looks like karen
knightley we've been there we've done
that we see right through your funky hat
how was your weekend my weekend was
really nice you know
very
baby-oriented i was just home with
harold and it was lovely but i didn't do
anything you know
memorial day
so i will throw the question back to you
well my weekend was great i went to
brian's farm um which was just premium
he's been doing so much work on it so
the pool was ready so many of like his
main house has been totally renovated so
it was just like so nice and i like
going there it's like the perfect combo
of like being relaxing doing like
classic you know we had a barbecue we
went out on the river very like american
memorial day things and then we went out
in philly one night so it was like the
best of both worlds you know yeah
speaking of the best of both worlds um
i just the whole time i was in brian's
farm i kept referencing how like this
his farm and his property looked so much
like crowley corners and nobody knew
what i was talking about because it was
people are sick no it was sick it was
like
me ben and like three gay guys who had
never seen
ben's never seen it ben had seen it once
like years ago so he kind of knew what i
was talking about but one night i was
like you guys we are going to watch this
movie and i was expecting one thing
about brian is like you watch something
with him he will fall asleep like even
if it's something he wants to watch he
will fall asleep anytime anywhere it is
so annoying like we're getting into
something and all of a sudden this is
what i hear
it's so annoying so i'm like i know that
they are going to fall asleep before we
get to the movie but whatever at least
i'll get to enjoy it when i tell you
couldn't get enough
so much so they wanted to go back and
watch the first ever episode of hannah
montana to get like some more context
now it's funny having you know showing
that movie to grown adults who like
obviously if you don't have the
nostalgia attached to it is it still
that good well yes they were like
quaking they could the climb like it was
dead silent they wanted to listen to it
afterwards on the boat they were like
can you put that song on they were
obsessed but it's really interesting how
like we all watched that when we were we
all watched hannah montana movie when we
were really young and so i was showing
the movie to 30 year old men who
couldn't get past the biggest plot hole
in the film they're like so nobody
recognizes her when she just puts a
blonde wig on robbie ray stewart is a
famous country singer but they don't
know who his daughter is
even though there's like wikipedia like
all the really glaringly obvious plot
holes that we as kids like didn't really
notice they couldn't get over it like
they it almost ruined it like okay i
will say yes she puts on a wig they
don't know her but there was something
like she really did look very different
with the wig and without the weight
guess if you stared at the foch you or
maybe kids in class would be like you
sometimes look like montana in this like
like her voice
but nobody thought she was it wasn't
that unbelievable i just want to say
like that wig was very distinguished
especially in the beginning when she
went from just being miley to like the
long blonde hair in the hand montana in
the movie it's like a shorter wig and so
it's a little more similar no she has
bangs still but it's like not as
wig like it's more of a normal haircut
whereas i think that
it works it's different than clark ken
and his sunglasses yeah but like okay so
she's hanging out with lucas till like
for two weeks they're getting to know
each other so much and then hannah comes
to town and has a conversation face to
face with lucas till and like he's not
supposed to know yeah no he is an
optimist
but you know some of the other more
ancillary characters yeah it's
believable yeah yeah they're just not
like we always say they're not thinking
about her they're thinking about their
themselves they're like oh my god i just
meant had montana like did i have [ __ ]
in my teeth right i guess
hannah montana and her wig pales in
comparison to hilary duff and her eye
mask in another cinderella story yeah or
a cinderella story whichever one it was
all of them all of them that that movie
is like infuriating to watch yeah i know
it's so good by the way they keep making
it there's a cinderella yeah another
cinderella one more cinderella story and
each time it's like
she's just wearing no like a cinderella
story she wore an eye mask and she
clearly had blonde hair and he's going
around looking for her in all these
different places talking to brunettes
and redheads like
are you blind
or are you blind well she could've been
wearing a wig
true
but like height for example you know
there was just a million things like
literally just her eyes were covered not
even like you could still see her eyes
just her under eyes it was so stupid
beyond beyond um so i had a great
weekend lots of fun in the sun even
though you would never know because i'm
pale as a ghost speaking of pale i broke
my legs out today for the first time
since last summer because i was like
pregnant i didn't go on vacation so i
just like was covered up and it's so hot
in the city i was like i'll be a fool
the tick tockers will make fun of me if
i'm wearing pants today and i wanted to
wear shorts you know embrace summer my
legs were so pale so i like put on some
santropay but it's the kind that's like
gradual it goes on clear so it doesn't
help my tan develops
over the course of the show what i
should have put on was kkw beauty yeah
but i just didn't have enough time to
perfect it my shoes were already on so
yeah like the thing about having legs is
that it's so much work and the bigger
the leg the more surface area
yeah of course more hair to shave more
surface area to cover with spray tan
more like ingrown hair more availability
surface area for ingrown hairs it's
horrible like having legs is literally
so exhausting pale ones pale ones big
pale ones big ones pale ones curly ones
disgrace queen make sure to watch it so
you know what we're talking about
tick-tock oh yeah if you're new here at
tick tockers i uh so let's should we
introduce ourselves like
totally okay because i actually have a
feeling like there might be some new
listeners i'm dead serious because some
people said i'm gonna listen yes they
said it okay so we're sisters like not
sister like sisters
we've been doing the show for four years
it is our full-time jobs we are content
creators i'm also a comedian so i go out
on tour i have a comedy special it's
available for free on amazon prime it's
called claudia ashrae disgraced queen um
so that's what i do jackie just had a
baby i did just have a baby uh we love
doing the toast we talk about pop
culture but we really just talk about
ourselves but if something big happens
like we'll let you know and we'll also
talk about stuff that you don't really
need to know on wednesdays we give
advice a fun thing to drop at a dinner
party you know we'll always give you
things in which to start conversation um
jackie's older than me a lot of people
think that i'm older because i'm fatter
but i'm actually just older just younger
and fat yeah um
so i'm 20
how old am i don't give don't tell them
yes
i'm 19. we're both in our 20s that's all
you need to know yeah early 20s yeah
yeah um and we love each other we love
the toast we both have dogs that are
king charles cavaliers this is bruno but
we call him bryce bruce streisand
whatever this is theo we call him tiggs
tiggity crunch crunch master general
thrice thrice strice they're the streis
brothers together they're brass and
straws and presents trash and rats and
strats and rats and straws and rats and
stress and um you will hear us talk
about our dogs as if they're human
beings so just
don't be alarmed but jackie also does
have a human being son yes exactly and
what else we have two other sisters
olivia and margo we also have a podcast
network called toast news network so if
you like what you see here we have tons
of other podcasts mood with lauren
elizabeth if you guys know lauren
elizabeth from youtube and instagram and
she's big on tick tock too um she has a
podcast with us we have our little
sister has a podcast called the snatcher
where she talks about the bachelor but
also just like regular life single girl
in new york city
so excited for this week's snatcher
because she couldn't have been more
fabulous this weekend i know i can't
every party that was happening satchel
was there we also have margaret josephs
from the real housewives on our podcast
network jackie hosts a book club podcast
once a month called the redhead spelled
r-e-a-d heads we are recording this
month's episode actually today the book
this month was run rose run by james
patterson and dolly parton and i'm so
proud to announce that we've broken the
curse it was good it was so good good
good it was so good and i think
everybody really liked it so far i read
a lot this weekend too i didn't make a
lot of headway because like i was busy
like being social but when i had a
minute i was getting really into sally
hepworth's new book it's really good
it's really good
so lengthy i love her like i love love
love sally but like i need your books to
be like 100 pages shorter you need every
book to be 100 pages short i need every
book oh
also for the new chick talkers i'm also
a published author a new york times
best-selling author you can write about
i mean you can read about my rise to
comedy getting cancelled and girl with
no job the crazy beautiful life of an
instagram thirst monster you can get it
anywhere you get books so audiobooks
ebooks hardcover amazon barnes noble all
the places love it and one other podcast
that we do have is girls night with
alexis waters from the bachelor who is
effing funny yeah and then also if
you're feeling thirsty while you're
consuming all this content check out
spritz society it's a delicious
sparkling cocktail with real wine real
flavors and real ingredients and if you
use kotos you can get 10 off that's our
company it's really good it's really
really good so we're just like
kind of like moguls
you know
[Laughter]
mogul energy
i literally like can't stop listing off
our accolades
you know do you know who i've okay you
know that okay i just realized who like
who i was doing okay i didn't even
realize i've been obsessed with hacks
new season okay and the assistant like
that was just her thing i haven't
watched the new season how is it it's so
good except oh my god i did like the
most embarrassing thing so i was posting
i was on a plane and i posted like so
excited about the new hack season and
they responded to me like love love and
i wrote back like a manifesto i was like
oh my god i love a show so much but like
please like cut ava's scenes she's in it
so social media manager doesn't do the
cut she's in it i said if the person
reading this like has any editorial
power like you are putting too much of
ava and not enough of deborah vance like
deborah is the queen like there's so
much ava content and we're also getting
um like other character development it's
like we don't need it like we just need
deborah vance yeah
but absence makes the heart grow fonder
and maybe if you got 75 percent deborah
you'd be like hey deborah's maybe not
all that she's cracked up to me so
they're on tour so they're like all on a
tour bus together that for the season
great it's really good like i just wait
to watch it's so they're releasing two
episodes every week so i think there's
like six now oh i'll just wait till it's
over it is annoying but that was the
character she's always like should we
like
have a beanie collada like that's always
what she's doing so i didn't even
realize like my mannerisms that's the
energy i was channeling that's really
funny i guess we are moguls no it's like
we're sitting here trying to list off
all of our business ventures and like we
can't stop and i'm sure we've forgotten
for sure like we have merch oh patreon
like mark page we are like i said
moguls totally so now i guess we should
show you what we do right so this is the
show so usually in the beginning we'll
like kiki catch up with each other
live action role play about our dogs and
then we'll get into the fast five so the
fast five is five pop culture stories we
pick every day also we do the show every
weekday like most weekdays um
weekdays where we feel like it
and we'll do the top five pop culture
stories of the day
we'll make fun of celebrities we'll gag
over the kardashians depends on how
we're feeling sometimes we'll be like
really negative sometimes we'll be
really positive just depends on the day
but it does seem as though we're feeling
positive today it's a short week we went
viral
everything's great except for our legs
except for our legs on wednesdays we do
a segment called deer toasters so if you
want advice from two people to moguls
you can write into deertoasters
gmail.com and that'll be on tomorrow's
show on mondays we do a segment called
unburden yourselves where you can email
us on burden yourselves gmail.com and
just like get something off your chest
like did you do something embarrassing
over the weekend cm the social media
manager at hacks and tell her you wanted
more deborah van scene did you
accidentally like poop in someone's bed
like whatever it is write it to us and
we will officially let that burden go
for you that's what we do
we will carry the burden and then we
will let it go it's a total safe space
here all are welcome
so i think we should show people how
it's done okay without further ado it is
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
credit karma are you paying down old
credit card debt a personal loan could
be your solution loans usually come with
fixed monthly payments making them a
simple way to help pay off your credit
cards plus loans usually have lower
interest rates than credit cards do and
credit karma can help you find the best
option for you so if you're planning
ahead for a big expense don't put those
car repairs or medical bills on a high
interest credit card credit karma can
help you look for a low interest
personal loan that could save you money
while you pay off your purchase credit
karma uses your credit data to find loan
offers that are personalized to you so
you can have a better idea of what loan
amount you can get approved for credit
karma will even show you your chances of
approval so you can choose between loan
offers that you're more likely to get
and apply with more confidence comparing
loan offers on credit karma is 100 free
and it will not affect your credit score
and it could be saving you money so
credit karma apply with more confidence
today if you're ready to apply head to
creditkarma.com
loan offers to see those personalized
offers that's creditkarma.com
loan offers to find the loan for you go
to credit credit karma dot com slash
loan offers
gorgeous thank you credit karma you're
welcome get it karma karama
our first story some romance news
margaret quali confirms her engagement
with jack antonoff with pda picks
quailing
depends where you're from it's official
margaret quailly quali confirmed that
she and jack antonoff are engaged by
sharing sweet instagram selfies on
tuesday she captioned it oh i love him
the bride to be also kissed her fiance
chic in the social media uploads final
photo
very very cute we have different
feelings about this relationship yeah i
don't know i'm like
so random i feel like they're two peas
in a pod in a hipster pod they're
definitely like hipster energy growing
out their armpit hair not wearing
deodorant like yeah i feel that for sure
um i don't know i just feel like this is
so random because margaret quayley is
really on the up to become like one of
the premier actresses like of our
generation
and i feel like a lot of you know being
a celebrity is who you date and just
like to close yourself off to all those
opportunities by getting married like
couldn't be me oh well that i get but
you just happen to think that jack
antonoff is not a suitable suitor
whereas like i think he's one of the
biggest producers of our
you know i don't think i said that um i
think like i just that's what you said
before the show right like to be kept
between us you know what's wrong with
that no i don't know i just don't think
like because of taylor you don't want to
smear anything that she does you are
like really like putting me on the spot
right now no i just i don't know i'm not
attackers how do you feel i'm not
i'm not like living for this that's what
i'll say and i would say that i am alive
for this for this but you know that she
dated pete davidson who is the eligible
bachelor
and how did you feel about that when
they were dating i wasn't really
familiar with her like she kind of came
up super sneaky like random you know my
first literally
my first
like interaction with margaret quailly
where i first like heard her name was
during kovid when her her sister and her
mom like were going for a walk in the
park and like the park was closed and
the paparazzi caught pictures of them
like sneaking into a park i'm like oh my
god andy mcdowell has two sickening
daughters two sickening daughters i'm
obsessed with both daughters
her name is rainey she goes by rainsford
and she's a singer and actress and
actually spoiler alert she's who i'm
going to cast as annie lee keys in the
hollywood champion through the redheads
because she's an amazing singer and
she's a really good actress and i and
she's like margaret caliber
got it yeah okay so that was like my
first
and then i watched maid so i'm not like
super familiar with margaret quailly
like
her discography she was also in once
upon a time in hollywood i didn't see it
oh so good i know it's just like i never
it never happened for me it should
happen for you like one night when
you're at tpg's looking for something to
watch yeah no i it just i'm not against
it in any way but the opportunity never
presented itself okay that we have to
work on that also like i think we need
to see top gun we have a story about it
okay yeah yeah we need to talk about it
yeah must must anyways i'm here for this
congratulations to the happy couple not
to be like a negative like doubter
non-believer
i don't see these two actually getting
married
that's a trend too yeah i don't hate
that no in celebrity culture like
getting engaged doesn't like really mean
getting married so if this is just that
then i'm here for it yeah just an excuse
to wear a ring and wipe yourself up and
get pressed and not sign anything right
not fork over you know half of your
community property yeah but they both
have a lot of community property
yeah he probably has more yeah but he's
also older yeah
he's had such a bizarre dating history
seven and he's 38.
well he's older than i thought he would
be yeah but he's been around for a while
and he's dated like the most he like
doesn't have a type like if you look at
all the women he's dated like they
couldn't look less different less
more different well lena dunham lord
i think lord and margaret look kind of
yeah
women lord had really curly hair doesn't
she still no
all right that's how i remember her yeah
me too i'll always remember her that way
are you ready for our next story which
is some more engagement news that i
absolutely have to get your thoughts on
oh yeah
foreign i really like did not want to
come on here and be negative today but
you are testing you're keeping it light
in there like you're keeping it positive
but former bachelorette becca kufrin has
proposed to her boyfriend thomas jacobs
former bachelorette becca kufrin is
engaged to thomas jacobs after less than
a year of dating and she proposed she
posed it to instagram on sunday it's
saying in the ultimate plot twist he
said yes we've been keeping the secret
just between us and close family and
friends for a while but we're so excited
to shout it for the rooftops she called
him her chauffeur for life and the one
who makes my heart smile every single
day i wonder if she doesn't have her
license either
i can't wait to do it all with you tommy
thanks for making me the happiest gal
alive i love you to the moon and back
and then he posted and said ultimate uno
reverse card and power move you keeping
me on my toes for a lifetime has a great
ring to it
okay
so before i say anything i have a few
just like
precursors i really like becca kufrin
like i want her to be happy i think
she's a nice great girl i don't know i
stopped watching the bachelor a long
time ago so i don't know the story with
this guy in paradise paradise i don't
know anything about him
again happy for her and i am like a
card-carrying feminist like i believe in
equality for all like you will not catch
me not empowering women okay no we we
couldn't couldn't you will never catch
me not empowering women
with that said
this could just never be me and of
course everyone is on their own journey
but like it will never and i am married
for the new tick tockers like i've been
married since i was like 14. like
no i've been so she's four she's four
marriage um
and maybe this is just like me being
like toxically traditional but this will
just never be me this is not a thing i'm
looking like
you know as women we've made so much
progress i think we've made a little too
much progress like this is i just in my
opinion like i think it crosses the line
honestly yeah um with you it's not for
me
but again like i'm not going to judge
anyone else i'm not a journalist i'm
just saying one's yeah yes but like if
you were to ask me like would you ever
do this like
no
okay if i were to ask you do you want to
see more of this
the thing is like i just want other
people to be happy so i'm stuck between
like being really negative but also like
wanting happiness for others yeah and
everyone's happiness looks different but
again it could never be you right could
never be me no wouldn't be me either
it's just like it's a choice you know
yeah it's a choice it's
like i think there's so many things that
are wrong with like gender stereotypes
but the man proposing to the woman is
not one of those things there's a lot of
things that i are right with the
stereotypes right like there are a lot
of things that i would hold true too
right like okay i'm a woman you're a man
like you're carrying the suitcases put
my bag up in the overhead storage
compartment and you are paying for
dinner like
you are getting my door
you are driving me around like yeah
there are certain things like
i like about sometimes i do think you
know maybe i was meant to be born like
in the era where women didn't have to
work
um because don't get me wrong like i
said love this job but like sitting at
home all day
it's not a bad life
yeah but then you're a stay-at-home mom
which is actually the hardest job
i have a whole new i want to be like a
stay-at-home wife like
a housewife yeah no i i do have a whole
new outlook on gender roles since having
a baby oh i'm sure i mean it's like it's
literally unfair beyond right so it's
like i have to carry the child feed him
from my breast literally tear my body
apart like you can get down on your knee
you buy the ring because she's not
wearing a ring in these photos he's
wearing a band oh so if a man propose if
a woman proposes do you get a ring he
got a ring and in the pictures she's
wearing a band like a wedding band and
he's wearing a wedding band so she
probably bought both for herself yeah
yeah
and i'm just i'm really exclusively
talking about um hetero relationships
you know because i think in gay
relationships the person who proposes
gets buys two rings also right so i'm
just exclusively speaking on my
experience and i'm not really i really
don't want to yuck other people's yums
it's just like it's not for me
yeah well you know what i'm reading down
in the article this is her third
engagement you gotta switch it up oh
wait because she wasn't getting shari
right that like shouldn't count that
should not i thought she had like an
engagement before the show no garrett
that does not count but i guess if i'm
her and this is my person i've been
engaged three times i want to do
something different this time yes which
is the difference yeah no i i can put
myself in that headspace i can get
behind it and i i support i support her
it's just not something i would
personally ever do and it's like one of
these new you know
progressive trends that i'm just
personally not on board with i really
haven't seen much of it so no it's
totally a thing like
i don't know anyone else me no me
neither but i like see it on tick tock
oh hey chick talkers hey guys and if
you're having fun do it
still here great
are you ready for our next did we turn
you off with our toxic gender
stereotypes with our toxic
traditionality traditionality are you
ready for our next story um some big
movie news
is it the big movie news that's brought
to you by purple yes it is because
you'll be sleeping good after you watch
this movie there are all these gimmicks
that promise a great night's sleep but i
don't care what kind of toppers they are
or how heavy the blanket might be it's
lipstick on a pig because if you're
sleeping on a terrible mattress your
sleep will be terrible and it's that
simple and that's why we recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress that's
because only purple mattresses have the
fl gel flex grid unlike memory foam
which remembers everything thanks to the
gel flex grid purple mattresses bounce
back as you move and you shift you'll
never have that unstuck feeling people
get with memory foam so with the purple
mattress a lot of you guys know i
have a beloved pillow on my bed called
the smelly pillow and it is from purple
it is the gel flex material and it is
amazing and a whole mattress made out of
that is literal heaven heaven just want
to let you guys know that the pillow
didn't come smelly that was yeah no the
body is special no slight to purple they
have clean beautiful smelling pillows
i'm a disgusting bees who made it smelly
try your purple mattress risk-free with
free shipping and returns and financing
is available as well getting a great
night's sleep starts with having a great
mattress get a purple mattress when you
go to
purple.com tmt and use code tmt that's
tmt as in the morning toast for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
tmt code tmt for 10 off any order of 200
or more purple.com tmt promo code tmt
terms apply gorgeous our next story top
tom cruise scores first 100 million
opening with top gun maverick the 59
year old superstar just got his first
100 million dollar opening weekend with
top gun maverick in its first three days
in north american theaters the long in
the works sequel earned an estimated 124
million dollars in ticket sales
paramount picture set on sunday and
including international showings its
worldwide total is 248 million dollars
it's a supersonic start for a film that
still has the wide open skies of
memorial day itself to rake in even more
cash so this was on sunday so i think
tom cruise should be thanking miles
teller like
previously i think you should be
thanking kelly sperry because the
content she's posting on instagram i'm
gonna go see this movie and i've never
even seen cop gun one okay so the kids
on tick tock are absolutely quaking like
they all saw top gun over the weekend
like because their you know friends
wanted to see like cool planes and they
all like this younger generation has
discovered miles teller oh i'm happy for
them and they are in for a treat they
are beyond quaking so now like a lot of
the older people on tick tock are
recommending like whiplash um
project x like a lot of his early work
when he was like you know footloose
footloose yeah remember when i made you
watch that recently unbelievable and
that scene where the kids are teaching
him how to dance it just doesn't get
like better cinema it doesn't and
so there's a lot been a lot of miles
teller discourse miles teller like
thirsting on tick tock and kelly sperry
entered the conversation and made a tick
tock of like her and miles just like
being cute you know they go to the
maldives a lot so there's a lot of like
cute it was like a montage to this love
the taylor's version oh my god i'm
quaking and i also saw she posted like a
video montage of their time in can and
like the top gun promotion and now
you're saying that's in response to the
fanfare so i think she just needed to
like stake her claim because like all
these young kids are like oh my god
miles teller miles teller and you know
their relationship is super private so a
lot of people might not even know upon
initial discovery that he's married so
she just had to set the kids straight
she set the record straight her video
got like millions of views wait wait
until they discover that she's in the
taylor swift music video with him have
they figured it out yet i don't know but
they're not ready they're not ready one
step at a time talkers maybe we'll be
the ones since so many tick tockers are
watching right
they'll learn from us follow us
uh follow her actually you can follow me
on instagram at jackie australia really
really premium stuff
so here's who else is in the movie miles
teller obviously glenn powell who i love
do you oh my god as an actor i love him
yeah cause he's from he's in all my
favorite things like scream queen yeah
hidden figures john gwen hidden figures
yeah oh i can't swoon yeah and
like everything he's in i just love
jon hamm
loves yes a lot of sexy men in this
movie jennifer connolly yes i saw that
she was in can i'm like that is so
random i totally forgot about jennifer
connelly and then two people ed harris
see the guy from uh hangover
he's from
[Music]
he's very familiar but how do we know
him is he from the hangover i'm gonna
find out show me a picture
he's a very familiar fox
you're gonna say i don't know him no
i've never seen that man before no i'm
gonna find out who he is hold on and val
kilmer oh ed helms i think it's the guy
oh yeah yeah yeah from the hangover val
kilner
and who's that throwback he's like the
og uh batman or something
val kilmer
yeah or like bond one of those it's like
an iconic roll
okay one second sorry tick-tock it's an
episode of fred we usually have these
things on the tip of our tongue
actually we spend a lot of time on imdb
okay
uh i don't know we'll you guys will yeah
like almost 100 sure about conor's like
the og batman very very cool yeah so
it's a star-studded thing i don't feel
like people have really given a [ __ ]
about top gun in years
so it's nice that the franchise is
making um a return i do
have like hate in my heart for tom
cruise
i i oscillate
he just like f like finances all of
scientology so it's like this movie
doing well you know yeah it's like
another check for scientology i know
yeah
but people why do people love him so
much
do they yeah this is because of tom
cruise really that i mean of course for
us it's like miles teller and like the
younger jed and also top guard and so
iconic but like he's a major movie star
and like people show up for him that's
so weird to me because like i don't
claim tom cruise is like a celebrity you
know yeah but like he's maybe it's just
like a generational thing like people
who grew up with tom cruise and like
they can't quit him they grew up
watching the movies it's like oh another
one why wouldn't i see it it's memorial
day weekend yeah they can't quit them
but this is also just big movie news
because everything since coveted has
pretty much been a flop yeah even the
things that you would think would not
flop have
underperformed no it's big for the
theaters yes so that's really shocking
that this is the one you know it wasn't
west side story that wasn't going to be
the thing that was going to get people
out even downton i was saw on the news
that like the fans of downtown are
people of a certain age and they're not
going to the theaters thus it has
impacted i do vodka
i do think it was a mistake of downton
to release the film exclusively in
theaters like so many
movie studios are getting more creative
like releasing it on itunes also so you
could like spend a premium like how
disney did mulan like you had to buy it
i just think like they could have been
more creative because you're right like
first of all people are going to the
theaters less and less and the people
who watch downton like are older yeah
yes and also like we have all been
cooped up for two years at home watching
tv you finally get out of the house i
don't think you're gonna go watch a
movie no it's true it feels unnatural
yeah like we've been doing this at home
we can't keep doing it at home yeah i
haven't seen downton no me neither and
it's like dying too and i imagine
they're gonna do some sort of like
on demand something and i'm just gonna
wait me too
even though it looks mad good and i
heard such good things really i'm going
to say it so bad and for some reason
i've heard like something big happens oh
no like you know nothing really happened
in the first one right it was just
keepness maybe we just need to spend a
day at the theater and like see all
these movies i know but one time that
was my dream to do a double header and i
did it i saw greatest showman for the
fourth time in theaters and then molly's
game right after i was with you no well
actually i think it was the opposite and
i didn't have enough time to process the
first movie
it's it sounds better than it is yeah
a day at the movies like actually sounds
amazing seeing movie after movie but you
need time to let it ruin it
to really process your feelings it
wasn't for me no i i hear that
are you ready for our next story
speaking of more movie news yeah you
told me about this fans are accusing oh
and this is another movie i want to say
danzar we'll add it to the little header
day but that's never going to happen
fans accuse austin butler of changing
his voice to sound more like elvis after
filming biopic
so
claudia told me that you know there's
been a lot of fanfare for austin butler
obviously the elvis movie looks so good
claudia's the source for this story
because this article let me tell you it
has too much detail but she said the
kids are turning on austin butler like
the the discourse around austin butler
shifted really quickly because people
does people discovered austin butler
like we're quaking quake and quaking and
he was just in can and elvis did like a
huge thing in can they obviously had the
premiere they did a huge party they've
been like really spending a lot of money
on this movie and the promotion so that
means we got a lot of um red carpet
moments with austin he did like a bunch
of like gq we've gotten a lot of austin
content and a lot of people are like
wait
why are you talking like that like he's
literally like going in and out of like
an accent and so now it's come out so he
did method acting for elvis he pretended
he was elvis for like three years um
and now he is like i guess having a
difficult time getting out of that
headspace and it's just like
as handsome as he is like i've been
watching a lot of his interviews and
like it's giving cringe
this is something i really can't relate
to like i can't relate to you know
method acting for two years and then not
being able to come back to who you are
and like still acting role playing as
elvis i guess i larp all the time maybe
it's the same thing yeah larping is
someone other than myself i think method
acting is insane and it puts so much
pressure because if austin butler is
like not great in this movie like it'll
be so awkward it's like you gave it
everything there was nothing you held
back maybe
maybe acting's not for you he did get a
12-minute standing ovation and can but i
feel like we hear that all the time yeah
maybe they just like to stand yeah
maybe
they needed a good stretch yeah i think
it will be good but we should see it
yeah that's definitely something i do
want to see one because austin butler
and two because they've been doing a
really good job at like marketing it
yeah especially on social media like for
a movie i think it's like the most
content i've seen come out of a movie in
a really long time like it's giving 2008
you know interesting i haven't seen any
but i'm not on like yeah elvis for the
film is all over tech talk like they
flew out these tick tockers oh right you
told us it was it's like they had a big
party it's been like a big affair okay
very cool it's crazy that all these
movies are coming out at this time of
year
usually summer is not
movie season yeah like this is giving
christmas yeah or like pre-oscar
buzz
so yeah downton elvis and top gun like i
really need to get to the theater yeah
or they need to put them on the
streamers yeah and i would purchase the
price of a movie ticket or you know if
i'm watching with others several movie
tickets yeah i guess that's a thing like
you probably don't make as much money on
demand no but like if you want to
sell it for 50 then i'll get four people
with me yeah and we'll watch you know i
just um i can't i can't do it like i
can't get to the theater no no
no i can't do it
are you ready for our fifth and final
story another claudia explains it all oh
yes tick-tock drama mama drama so you're
telling me it's a final story yes it is
it's the final story
[Music]
thank you my friend okay fifth and final
story mom talk drama please explain it
to us lay people
so the internet really like turned
itself upside down over the weekend okay
because there was this group of tick
tockers who like had a following but
like nobody really cared like they were
just like they were these really cute
young pretty
moms
from utah mormon they had all these
husbands and they were all just like
really handsome they just like do dances
together the one who i think was like
the biggest in terms of platform and
also like the only person whose content
i had seen before this whole thing blew
up was this girl named taylor and i knew
where she has hair down to her ankles
and she washes it literally once a month
and she washes it in a bathtub and like
her hair washing method is so crazy like
she doesn't get in the tub she leans
over the tub puts her dirty hair
that she doesn't wash
in the water
rubs shampoo and it leaves the dirty
water in the
in the tub rubs shampoo all over her and
she doesn't even get like the back of
her neck so she gets like half her hair
covered in shampoo dips the hair back
into the dirty water and does the same
thing with conditioner so like that was
really what i knew her about like not
the fact i didn't care that she was more
man i didn't care like about anything
else
so over the weekend no like last at the
end of last week things started to
happen like people started unfollowing
each other
and
people were quaking and this girl taylor
went on live and basically like
told everyone she's getting divorced
and why she's getting divorced is
because
a recent stream of like toxic
things had happened
so her and her group of mormon couples
had decided to start soft swinging which
i think is the difference between soft
swinging and swinging is like
your partner has to be
present if you're going to be with
someone else so it's like not like
totally like 100 swinging but they all
started like [ __ ] around and this
girl taylor like started
connecting with one of the other girls
husbands
and
had like an extramarital affair in the
sense that they used to like mess around
when no one was around when they weren't
swinging and therefore was taking it too
far they were also drinking a lot which
was like very against their mormon
beliefs and it got to a place that was
you know just so bad and she was like
seeing this other guy that her and her
husband decided to get divorced and she
blew it all up but she wouldn't say what
other content creators were involved so
now it's just left the internet
speculating about all these people's
marriages which is like kind of [ __ ]
up like what you do in your private life
is like really none of our business
but now all these other people have
banded together to like offer some sort
of like rebuttal which is basically that
like
this girl taylor was having an affair
anyways and like she made up this whole
story to like
implicate everyone instead of just like
admitting that she just had an affair on
her husband but were they soft swinging
we don't know the thing is now it's just
like he said she said yeah it's like
maybe they were stop swinging but that's
irrelevant to the story and you just had
to like blow up everyone's spot what
because you your own was blown up right
like they were all having fun like being
crazy drinking and swinging which is not
a crime um and you had to like blow it
all up because you took it too far right
i don't know i'm like not on the og girl
side i mean i know
very little but from what i know it
sounds like
people are not on the og girls side they
see through what she was trying to do i
don't know i don't know and that she was
acting nefariously and also that she was
kind of the ring leader of the group
sort of like she was the most popular on
social media at least and maybe in the
tic-tac videos like she's always in the
front which yes that says everything you
need to know so you know like the ring
leader is not in the back connor and
that
i'm just you know for my pov like if she
was the ring leader like i could see if
she was the one who got them into
swinging yeah for sure but also this
clip of her doing an interview recently
like has resurfaced um because she said
that she um had interviewed for the real
housewives of salt lake city but they
said like her life wasn't dramatic or
controversial enough so maybe this is
her way of
becoming dramatic and controversial
right which is like to take all of your
friends down with you like that's [ __ ]
up yeah i don't know like
it just left a bad taste in my mouth
because even if everything she's saying
is completely true like
what everyone chooses to do in their
personal lives is really not fodder for
the internet you know even though you're
all friends from the internet and like
she had an affair she made a mistake
instead of just saying like i had an
affair i made a mistake it's like well
we were all doing this and i just took
it a little too far that's like not
being accountable no that's so true it's
making excuses yeah and putting other
people in harm's way and on the internet
and other people with kids like i don't
know it's just
like they didn't take it too far this is
not their problem yeah and now
everyone's just left speculating like
which other couples
are involved because and she's like she
she made it a point to say like who
wasn't like
who wasn't involved thus like leaving a
[ __ ] starter yeah leaving the potential
candidates like fairly obvious yeah i
don't like that either tell us or don't
tell us yeah i don't know what i i
really didn't like this girl's content
before because i was like just get in
the shower like the bath
tub washing her hair like really stuck
with me um and now i'm just like
you made your life a mess and you're
taking everyone down with you and like i
don't think that's cool no but in being
taken down they're also all being
uplifted because this stuff is
everywhere i didn't know any of these
people
and now i'm sure they are too going
viral such as us you know who we need on
the show to kind of debrief it with us
rachel parcell yeah cause she's kind of
the eyes and ears of the mormon utah
content creator community 100
and i feel like i would really like to
hear her take maybe we'll have her call
in yeah we should just add it to like a
master list of questions for each we
actually need to start a google doc of
things we need to ask rach parcell when
the day comes that she will be on the
show and i'm telling you that day's
coming the last time she was here she'd
literally jam me like let's podcast and
then she got busy and like never
answered me but like it's on her radar
it's on her radar and it has to be in
studio because we need the power of race
or
or
we fly to her and record in her home
like excuse to go to utah sign me up and
excuse me take pictures of the inside of
her house so i can one day buy my own
house and literally copy it literally
so yeah everything leads back to rage
yeah it's
so true
um so yeah mom talk is like blowing up
it's really not that
um
well i think people are you know
scandalized interested in the fact that
these people are swinging yeah and
that's not something you see every day
and that they're mormon which like you
definitely don't see swinging every day
but you definitely don't see it in the
morning community well there was that
like swinging thing on real house eyes
with whitney remember lisa barlow
accused her of swinging maybe it is
popular in the mormon community because
no disrespect to mormons but like a lot
of mormon culture like
seems boring like pinterest they're
livening it up yeah and you know what
like do you think
that there's some you know
swinging in utah happening out more than
perhaps elsewhere or maybe more people
swinging you just don't know well so
because you're not supposed to know
because it's people's private business
then swinger culture like has been you
know been now been discussed on tick
tock so like you know the official
symbol of swinging is the pineapple no i
didn't know that it's the upside down
pineapple so like if you're in the
grocery store in like your local town
and somebody in their cart has a
pineapple upside down it's like a signal
to other couples like that we do this
if you like in your front yard you might
have like a pineapple sign like it's a
sneaky way of like sending a signal
which is like nice they have like that
but now we're like blowing it up so it's
not really a secret thing anymore
because they need to come up with a new
signal this is so fascinating what does
swinging remind you of
um
our childhood
no for me it's that episode of the oc
with the watches
yeah they go to the swingers party and
like they put the watches in a bowl yeah
but now it's reminding me i feel like i
just watched a show
sex life remember they went to a
swingers party got it and things went
awfully you never watched it no things
went sideways immediately i imagine that
they can it's a precarious situation i
don't know i don't think i could be into
swinging
for like a multitude of reasons well
yeah like i would have to follow ben
around the party and that would be no
fun for him
well that would be soft swinging then
yeah and like i don't know other people
like
are just like they don't do it for you
no like
nobody takes showers anymore you know
yeah um
i guess
like people on tick tock are like
normalized never showering for two weeks
i'm like don't get don't get me wrong i
hate showering like i will do it as
little as possible but like i still do
it multiple times a week you know yeah
no i'm not familiar with this
trend no like this
literally this girl went viral she was
like did you know you literally don't
have to put soap on your arms or legs
i mean putting soap on this you know the
top of your thigh what's there i mean
today i had my thighs out but generally
there's there no but if you're wearing
pants all day
why do you need to lather the top of
your kneecap you know if you're just in
the shower like you might as well do it
at all might as well but really you
don't have to it's what she's saying
yeah it was just like like a lot you
know
like let's just haul shower you know
yeah that's like a private thought you
can have in the shower like hey my
kneecap didn't touch anything today yeah
no it's fine let the suds just wash down
on it i don't need to like actively go
seek out a kneecap scrubbing and i also
don't need to make a tick tock letting
you know that i'm not washing my arms
like don't put your arm around me if
you're like not putting soap on your arm
you know yeah and i feel like before
covet i was like really like not
concerned with germs like at all like i
was like a dirty girl like i used to get
into my bed too dirty to clean her act
up
i used to get into my bed like in my
clothes in your street clothes and i
used to do it i used to like get home
from work and like eat something without
washing my hands
and i feel like i've really grown in the
last two years well that's a very
positive outcome yeah like the one
positive thing to come out of covid yeah
great well that's great that and like 40
pounds
don't get me started um should we talk
about the kardashians it was on on
thursday but obviously we didn't have a
chance to recap it we should talk about
it and any other tv that you watch this
week that was the only thing that i
watched i was reading all weekend i
watched rupaul's drag race all-stars
it's so good so they're doing an uh i'll
get into it in the tv recap segment
which is brought to you by frame bridge
frame bridge makes it easier and more
affordable than ever to frame your
favorite things without ever leaving the
house from art prints and diplomas to
the photos sitting on your phone you can
frame bridge just about anything with
father's day around the corner frame
bridge also makes the perfect gift in
fact
they have select gifts that shipping
that are shipping the next day go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo or
they'll send you packaging to safely
mail in a physical piece preview your
item online in dozens of frame styles
and gallery wall layouts choose your
favorite or get free recommendations
from their talented designers the
experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds
you pay at the framing store their
prices start at 39 and all shipping is
free plus my listeners will get 15 off
their first order at framebridge.com
when they use code toast order online at
frameridge.com or you can stop by one of
their stores to work with a designer in
person in new york dc atlanta philly
boston or chicago get started today
frame your photos or send someone the
perfect gift go to framebridge.com and
use the promo code toast to save an
additional 15 off your order just go to
framebridge.com promo code toast
framebridge.com promo code toast so it's
just really nice to like not have to
spend hundreds at a framing store franby
just frame bridge is so fast so easy and
it's really nice way to make your house
a home going to the framers is actually
a really toxic experience it's okay and
framebridge has just totally modernized
it i have some gorgeous frame bridged
items in my house obviously pieces of
art when i need a frame but i've also
found myself to be a piece of art and i
framed some photos of myself and it's
pretty cool like you ever take an artsy
pic and you're like am i slim errands
frame it normally frame it normalize
taking photos of yourself and framing
them 100
normalize treating photos of yourself
like works of art because they are okay
so really quickly i just want to talk
about rupaul's um
all-star so the first episode cameron
diaz was a judge and she was just being
like
everything was she being bad teacher no
she was being like a good teacher all
american
sweetheart girl next door like the girl
we love you know that's who she is so
this is the first time they do basically
two seasons a year where it's like the
regular drag race and then they do all
stars which is like people who made it
in the last couple seasons to like top
four or five so it's really it's a
strong competition but this time for all
stars they did all previous winners so
it's like there's not a bad
queen in the bunch so honestly i don't
really know who could win but i kind of
just want to predict that in a couple
weeks i can come back and see if i was
like totally off um i do think shay
coulee like is that girl um and i do
think that
like try as we may like she probably
will win
but
honorable mention to jinx monsoon okay i
know that means nothing too i just
wanted to put it out no but you know at
the end of the like in a few weeks when
it's done i'll remember who you said
yeah and i won't right so i need you to
listen yeah no i remember the names i
thought you were gonna say got mick
again no gottmake is not on um this
season and what's rose
oh my god why you really do remember
rosa like
i don't know i never really heard much
about rose after the finale but i'm sure
she like is they all do so well like the
show is so big like i cannot believe how
many people watch it like they all do
podcasts they do web shows they do tours
like and they make a lot of money like a
lot of the queens there's a couple
queens who are like in my opinion the
most
famous like simone from like two seasons
ago like she was at the met gala you
know i'm sure like i know you know you
don't know what i'm talking about but if
you saw a picture of her you'd be like
oh my god i've seen her like she goes
everywhere um
katya and trixie mattel they have a
podcast they just see them on the charts
when i go on tour they're like always
playing at the same theaters as me like
they they kill it they're always in the
charts yeah yeah so it's just like crazy
how like it's like the bachelor now like
you literally get a full-blown career
afterwards not even just doing drag
shows like other stuff yes also before
we get into kardashian's recap i feel
like there's been a few comedy specials
that have come out that i've been
meaning to talk about because um
speaking of podcasters
there's that special that i told you to
watch christine i know i didn't watch it
yet called mom jeans and it was so good
and especially like as a new mom it's
all about motherhood and it's [ __ ]
hysterical it's all about like parenting
now versus like in the 80s and i didn't
realize christina p is a comedian and
she's also a podcaster and she has a
podcast with her husband tom sagura
and
sagura i was like loving it and i always
see them on the podcast charts now i
know who they are familiarizing yourself
with our fellow competitors so good then
i watched krista stefano's especially
weshie i watched it too i thought it was
great it was and it was short which i
liked me too because all of these
specials that i've been watching and
liking like ricky gervais and also
christina p i like them but i never
finished them no same okay so like i
feel like your special really has to be
under an hour and if it's gonna be over
an hour you have to be making like a
grand like dave chappelle could go on
for however long he wants because he's
always making like a a statement that
from start to finish you have to keep up
in order to like
digest what his lesson was you know yeah
but for the most part i agree like 45 to
an hour let's let's keep it there yeah
like leave me wanting more i mean maybe
i'll come back to it but i just didn't
have the time and i also feel like a lot
of specials are coming out now because
it's like the netflix is a joke thing
yeah remember we like did a story about
how they're programming it so it's like
the beginning of june there's going to
be even more specials but i just feel
like netflix is having a specials moment
yeah i watch ricky gervais honestly i
didn't like it but you didn't or you did
i did not but he even said in the
beginning he's like
you know you don't have to he literally
said comedy's more personal than food
like which it is yeah so i don't know i
just thought like it was you know he was
being like crazy controversial and if
you're gonna do that like you have to be
like really funny and i don't know i
just it it wasn't landing for me oh okay
i enjoyed it it was like parts that i
watched yeah i i didn't like it um
and then did you see they uh
just announced you know norm mcdonald
from snl who passed away he had like
been secretly ill i guess while he like
knew his time was almost up he recorded
a special from his house um and it's
going to be on
netflix i think maybe it's up now but
relatively soon i saw the trailer for it
it's like deeply profound it's like
funny and also like final words it's
actually like it's crazy yeah oh i'll
watch that yeah um so you're right like
netflix is just like keeping comedy like
in business no they're just you know
they i feel like sometimes they have a
lot of reality shows everyone's talking
about like right now they're having a
special on special yeah and it's really
enjoyable and it's also like a fun
it's kind of like podcasting yeah and
then i watched some of krista stefano on
joe rogan but only like the first 45
minutes because it was kind of intense i
didn't know that much about krista
stefano and like his back story he talks
a lot about like his experience with
911. and it was just like a lot so i
i'll probably watch more but i needed to
break it up i really like chris 7-0 yeah
um i always like download his podcasts
listen to you on the plane digital
girlie like us yeah patreon yeah and he
started like do you remember where you
first sky code i of course love that i
saw him at caroline's
yes i was there rich oh right we went
carly
they used to date i know and we like
love them so much and we went and saw
them no you know what girl code and guy
code was like an iconic flash in the pan
like yeah and when you think about how
many people came aquafina nicole meyer
nicole byer
carly aquilino chris stefano more on oh
andrew schultz yep charlemagne
charlemagne they didn't come from it but
they were on it no and for me like that
was my first introduction to
most of them
nicole buyer i forgot melanie um i think
she's like big on instagram now i need
to find her but it's another person who
you know no it's crazy like that was
really the breeding ground for like a
lot of young comics and it was such a
good show yeah i never watched sky code
but girl code yeah you could relate
totally um okay so kardashian's on hulu
new episode
um what happened i don't even remember
oh i watched it recently so i can share
the courtney and travis's cleanse
courtney and travis's cleanse i'm just
like
that's fine that that's what they want
to do obviously not for me what would
never could could catch me but it's
really surprising that they're taking us
with them because like they look so
silly like travis with the thing on his
head like and he's like such an esteemed
drummer that's how little they care yeah
they're like we don't care what we look
like this is like genuinely who we are
and what we love to do and even though
they'll probably be like made fun of and
turned into memes like they don't give a
[ __ ] and i appreciate that yeah um did
you notice anything about their guru
no should i know her um i might be
related to her name was larry martinez
offer spelled
spelled the exact same way i did see
that is that crazy yeah you should talk
to ben did you ask him
oh man that was like what i was fixating
on the entire episode chloe's new house
is so nice so gorgeous chloe's home
taste even though all the girls have
gorgeous houses i would live in any of
them you know you i couldn't say a bad
word about any of them but if i had to
pick someone whose taste was most akin
to mine it is chloe jackie when i was
watching her home tour i'm like i want
to remind myself to say on the toast
that if i could live in any one of their
houses it would be chloe as well because
her priority is comfort like you can see
everything it's not like harsh lines
it's just plush the lighting it's like
moody
i totally agree and it's fun and it's
food you know she's the theater that's
the whole screen she has the pantry like
she just knows how to live and they all
do and i couldn't say a bad word
but
hers taste is just gorgeous and really
feminine whereas you know kim's always
doing like newfound
yeah which is like five years
but this is just she's very traditional
chloe yeah i love it that house is so
nice and living next to her mom is like
so nice so nice i love it for both of
them what else happened kylie and her
archive
wow 30 000 pieces and her style
midlife crisis that was like giving me
anxiety like so much clothing like
it's just crazy how kim like always knew
she was gonna be that [ __ ] because she
started archiving [ __ ] like when she was
a nobody yeah well i guess i'm sure more
people than you
would think a lot of people have clothes
and storage she calls it an archive and
you know if she wore a dolce dress 15
years ago like she was going to like
what else are you going to do with it
and then she wore that to uh
courtney's wedding did you see that was
that a dress she had already worn what
she posted to instagram it was a dress
that she wore like when she was like kim
k you know which is
look the black lace the black lace dress
she wore she purchased at bergdorf
goodman in 2011 and wore it to the
glamour awards when she was just but
hers was long sleeve then she added this
venomous dress she had in her closet oh
my god to make it look like for more of
a layered look oh i never would have
guessed isn't that an interesting
factory that i'm so glad that she shared
with us yeah that is really interesting
and that was actually really good
styling on her part but why is she
acting like she doesn't know how to put
an outfit together she was a stylist
first and foremost no i know and like i
i do give a lot of
like she does and i agree that like a
lot of her style is from kanye and it's
easy to become so dependent when you
want to think about something for years
because somebody is doing it better and
they're there to support you like
totally i understand becoming
codependent but it's like girl remember
who the [ __ ] you are yeah i it's feeling
like it's just a story line i don't
maybe it's a thought that she had like
oh who is my style post kanye post easy
like what should which designers am i
going to partner with but this whole
like journey that she's on it's a little
inauthentic considering she's always
been a fashion girly that's how she got
her start she was paris's stylist like
what are you seeing around town that
you're like you have a clothing line
like
yes
every day and also speaking of bee line
plots
chris and kylie going to the grocery
store and getting a car wash was giving
keeping up with the kardashians on e it
was but considering we don't get a lot
of kylie and i'm like pregnant kylie i
just like loved so dearly
i'm not complaining no and they were
like being funny in the grocery store
but like it was like a little silly no
it was silliness filler because nobody
told chris yet that they're not doing
that [ __ ] anymore right like we're back
to basics like we're being we're giving
substance right we're just in the car
having whatever conversation we would
have had not like gimmicks let's go to
the grocery store was kendall in this
episode
yes yes uh vogue
oh
that was crazy i didn't know where that
conversation was going with chris and
kim during kim's balenciaga shoot
and i was just like not expecting it to
go there and i actually had a lot of
respect for kendall like yeah at one
point i thought she was like gonna cry
but then she was like i don't have an
upset bone in my body and i can't
imagine why she would this girl has
covered every color there's no runway
that is closed to her what's one less
american vote cover no it's so true and
like
they all are
like they are doing what they're doing
because of the trail that kim blazed so
you have to give reverence and even if
she in her heart of hearts is upset at
least she knows well enough to not to
say it be upset because there's nothing
to be upset about you've been on the
cover of american vogue the fact that
it's between you and your sister just
shows how much you guys dominate the
industry like
it's many blessings on your head and i
liked getting a little sneak peek of
kim's vogue shoot and like anna on
facetime okay i just want to say they
juxtaposed like her vogue shoot with her
like coming out of her
fashion sense she styled herself and i
don't remember like what i said or how i
felt about the cover at the time and the
looks but like
it wasn't for me i liked the cover
without like structuring the cover came
out nice no but when she was in all
those outfits she was in all those
outfits and the voiceover is like i'm
finally picking the things that i love
and i'm like
that orange dress with the cutouts was
like
it was giving like fashion nova which
dress not the versace one no it was an
orange dress no no no no that was
gorgeous it had like cut outs all the
way to the floor
there was just a lot that was just not
for me yeah but it's nice how kim like
even though kim literally runs the world
like she has so much respect for vogue
and like anna and it's nice even though
like
she doesn't have to yeah and then she
apologized to the family for kanye
oh that was interesting and i wish she
like had went into slightly more detail
uh what i was referencing or thinking
about was you know when he would go on
those tweets and he would say too stuff
about chris and the family and
even like i feel like when he did like a
charlemagne interview
he didn't have like he didn't i don't
recall anything like overtly negative
but he just like was always kind of
trashing the family yeah like blowing up
though
and so that's you know probably was
frustrating for her in a weird place to
be in like as a wife and a mother and a
sister and a daughter but like
he
uplifted the family he legitimized them
like they were just you know your
average realities are so popular
but not like well respected yeah and
where they are now is in large part
it's in everyone's part everyone has
done their part and they made great
businesses but they he took them to a
level that they never even thought that
they could be at no it's true so it's
like i guess part of that is like you
have to deal with his wrath but like
going you're right
i wasn't sure what she was referring to
but i figured it was like the tweets and
likes lyrics and stuff
but
i don't know it's like
he could have legitimized them and also
not trash them you know
yes but i understand why at the time
maybe it's just
it's not like he was just trashing them
like they're literal they're sitting
around that table and like having this
conversation in this house like because
yeah a lot of what like he did yeah so i
i think that well you know like i love
them and they work hard and and they
deserve every like
but he i don't even remember because
like at post chris humphries it was dark
it was a dark time yeah for them and for
the fans too because it was like that
was not good that was no bueno no we
really felt like our like time was
wasted and
and and they had like cut and paste
some scenes in keeping up with the
kardashians to make him look better and
like we knew that it was like edited and
we just felt like used used much like
chris yeah
that was like not a good time you're
right so like it could have gone in a
different direction yeah and he really
came through yeah i mean you can see it
like as her being
her being his plus went to the met gala
and then literally as of this year like
owning the met gala like you don't get
there by chance right so that's what
just what i thought about it but it was
nice that she apologized to her family
and i just wish they could all get along
because i love everyone yeah and kim
doing her own contracts now like queen
queen
um so yeah it was a good episode and
then she posted this week i didn't want
to make it a story but like she was pda
with pete instagram this weekend that
was um that was a lot that was
overwhelming for sure yeah no it's it's
here and it's crazy they're so public we
know they're dating but every time they
post something like that like it's
shocked to the system again it's so it's
so crazy like when he kissed her like i
was not okay yeah
yeah and they're in london now unsure
what for people are speculating you know
what is the queen jubilee jubilee
hopefully the queen is a kardashian stan
as well but taylor um is also in london
do you think she's for the jubilee i
feel like she could be yeah more so than
kim 100 i thought the same thing because
they're having all these performances
yeah and she's a performer and her
husband boyfriend is british and you
know she loves a london boy i enjoy
nights in brixton shortage in the
afternoon right she could be singing
that she should be
london girl though for the queen
she's i love a london girl
girl
i fancy you so yeah that is your catch
up on all things tv pop culture and
us
us
anything else no uh redheads drops on
thursday so if you read the book
submit your questions to the
redheadsbookclub gmail.com it's gonna be
a great episode and it's never too late
to become a redhead and i do think that
this is the book you should start with
because it's a crowd pleaser for sure
written by dolly parton and james
patterson my first james patterson book
i know how do you feel it was really
good i i can see i can really see the
james and the dolly of it in the book it
was great yeah i love that yeah um so
that's our show thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
now
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio ir radio
cast box all the places so wherever you
listen to podcasts find us the morning
toast and leave a five-star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
hope you guys have an incredible and
crab day
in crayon we'll see you tomorrow for
hump day
goodbye goodbye